[MUSIC PLAYING]
VANESSA: Welcome
to Google Talks,
and today we have
the great honor
of having some of the world's
greatest medievalists here
at Google.
So I'd like to welcome
Simon Keynes, Claire Breay,
and Jo Story who are going to
be talking about the exhibition
at the British Library that's
still on called Anglo-Saxon
Kingdoms--
Art, Word, and War.
And just a show of hands,
how many people have
been to see the exhibition?
Good.
OK, well I'll turn
it over to Claire
from the British Library.
Claire, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
CLAIRE BREAY: Thank
you very much, Vanessa.
Well, the Anglo-Saxon
Kingdoms Exhibition
at the British Library
is the largest exhibition
that there's ever been,
covering the whole period
of the Anglo-Saxon
kingdoms, from the departure
of the Romans right
up to the Norman
conquest of 1066 and beyond.
And it looks at the
history and the literature
and the art of the
Anglo-Saxon kingdoms,
examining the original
evidence that survives
and bringing together some
of the greatest treasures.
The impetus for the exhibition
was the acquisition in 2012
of this little manuscript,
the "St. Cuthbert Gospel,"
in my hand there.
And that little book
weighs only 162 grams,
but it cost us 9 million pounds.
And so we had-- it's the
earliest intact European book.
And before its
acquisition, it was
the most important
English medieval
manuscript that was still
in private hands, I think.
And we wanted to sort
of mark that acquisition
by doing something
really on a large scale
about the Anglo-Saxon kingdoms.
The exhibition has
180 objects in it.
80 of those come
from the library's
own outstanding collection
of Anglo-Saxon manuscripts.
You can see one of the most
famous here, the "Lindisfarne
Gospels," made around 700.
And so 80 of the objects
come from the library's
own collection.
And 100 are loans.
The exhibition, I think, has
been popular for many reasons.
But I think one of the
sources of its success
is that it looks at the
beginnings and the foundation
of so many things.
It includes this manuscript,
which isn't actually
an Anglo-Saxon manuscript,
dates from the beginning
of the 12th century.
And it's called the
"Textus Roffensis,"
"Book of Rochester."
And it is the
earliest manuscript
that we have of English law.
So it contains the
laws of King Ethelberht
of Kent compiled around 600.
But it's also really
important because it's
the earliest
extended text that we
have that is written
in the English language
and the beginnings of
the English language
and English literature,
a theme running right
through the exhibition.
We also have in the exhibition
the first original charter
that survives on the
sheet it was written on,
on the left here, the
charter of [INAUDIBLE],, which
dates from 679, granting
land in [INAUDIBLE]..
And that is next to here
and in the exhibition
next to the Letter
of World [? Hera, ?]
which is the earliest
original letter that survives
from Anglo-Saxon England.
And this letter is
written in Latin.
So we have earlier
letters, but this one
survives on the original
piece of parchment
it was first written on.
And also in the exhibition,
we have this document,
in which the scribe didn't waste
any of the parchment at all.
This is the Fonthill Letter.
And its claim to
fame is that it is
the earliest letter
that survives written
in the English language.
It's a letter to Edward
the Elder telling
a tale of crime and punishment
about a disputed piece of land.
There are many very beautiful
manuscripts in the exhibition.
And this manuscript contains
this very famous image
of King Athelstan.
And it is the first
portrait that we
have of an English
king in a manuscript.
There are portraits
of kings on old coins,
but this is the first
one in a manuscript.
And here, King
Athelstan is presenting
a copy of [? Thebes ?]
lives of Saint Cuthbert,
the famous Northumbrian
Anglo-Saxon saint.
And he's presenting
this manuscript
to the community
of St. Cuthbert.
So as I said, the
exhibition has at its heart
80 manuscripts from the
library's own collections.
But we also have
these 100 manuscripts
and archaeological
objects on loan.
And we borrowed those
from 25 lenders.
And some of those
manuscripts have never
been seen in Britain before,
including this fantastic gospel
book, the [INAUDIBLE]
Gospels on loan from Paris
with this wonderful Lion of St.
Mark leaping across the page.
This was made around 700.
We have codex [INAUDIBLE],,
it's a giant Bible
made at the beginning
of the eighth century
and taken from
Northumbria to Italy.
It is one of the
greatest treasures
of Anglo-Saxon England.
And it has never
been back to England
in 1300 years, until the day it
was delivered for installation
in the exhibition.
We have this manuscript, not
an Anglo-Saxon manuscript.
This is the "Utrecht Psalter,"
"Book of the Psalms,"
made in the first half of the
9th century on the continent
and brought to
Canterbury, where it
was used as a model
for other manuscripts,
and it has these fantastic
cartoon-like strips,
decoration, illustration of
what is going on in the Psalms.
This manuscript was in the
collection of Sir Robert
Cotton, but he
lent it to a friend
and it made its way
to the continent.
And it's never been on
exhibition in Britain before,
and neither has this manuscript,
the [? Bocelli ?] book.
This is one of the four
principal manuscripts
of Old English poetry.
And we are displaying it
open at the poem known
as the Dream of the Rood.
So it's the dream
of the cross telling
the story of the crucifixion
from the cross' point of view.
And it's been in Italy for
nearly 1,000 years, at least.
And the loan of
that manuscript has
enabled us to display together
for the very first time
the four principal manuscripts
of Old English poetry, which
together contains 75% of
all the old English poetry
that survives.
And it's there, second on the
left, next to, on the left,
the unique manuscript
of "Beowulf"
from our own collections.
And if you've been
to the exhibition,
you will have seen that there
is a replica of the Ruthwell
Cross in the exhibition in
this language and literature
section.
And the Ruthwell
Cross, on its sides,
has inscriptions
in runes, which are
extracts from that poem,
The Dream of the Rood,
so you see it--
you see poetry on the parchment
pages but also on the stone.
And right at the end
of the exhibition,
we have "Domesday "Book,
the most famous book,
I think, in English history.
And of course, this isn't an
Anglo-Saxon manuscript either.
It was written up in 1086,
and it's on loan to us
from the National Archives.
And it's famous as a product of
Norman control and efficiency,
but actually, "Domesday
Book" tells us so much
that we can't see from any
other source about the landscape
and the organization and the
wealth of late Anglo-Saxon
England.
So it's absolutely
fantastic, unique evidence
for that period.
So I'm going to hand over
now, after that very brief
introduction, to Jo and Simon,
who are going to take us
through the centuries.
They're going to alternate,
looking at a manuscript
and then a charter
in turn to take us
into more depth about a few
of the highlight exhibits.
Thanks.
JOANNA STORY: OK.
Thanks, Claire.
Simon, you come here.
Right.
So I'm going to talk
about a manuscript,
Simon's going to
talk about a charter,
and the idea is that were going
to move through the centuries
seamlessly, all right?
And we've got about 3
and 1/2 minutes per item,
so if you see me
giving him a nudge,
it'll be because he's running
out of time and vise versa.
OK.
For those of you
interested in big data,
"Domesday Book" is big data
for Anglo-Saxon England.
Seriously, it's extraordinary.
OK.
Right.
It has started with your one.
You're going to start with--
SIMON KEYNES: It
seems that I'm going
to start with the Hlothhere
Charter, which you've just
seen.
This is the earliest
surviving original
of an Anglo-Saxon charter.
There are about 1,000 of them
that survived from the period
670 to 1066.
Of that 1,000, about 100
survive in their original form,
and this is the
earliest of them.
And it's dated 679.
It's a Charter of Hlothhere,
who was King of Kent.
It's granting land in Kent
to the Church of Reculver,
and it was--
it's dated 679.
It's dated by a system
called the indiction,
so it's not actually yet
the AD system of dating,
anno [? Dominicae, ?] which
we're so familiar with.
But we can work out
that this was 679.
We can also see
that it was drawn up
at the time of a meeting,
and it was produced and used
at the meeting.
And it's got the attestations
of the king here,
the signum manus
of Hlothhere King,
and then the attestations,
the signatures
of all of his leading men, and
they all have their crosses.
And this is the beginning.
You'll see four or five
more of these things,
but this is where it all starts.
Unsealed script, very
posh kind of script,
like the "Codex Amiatinus,"
so a fine thing.
JOANNA STORY: Oh, right.
We seem to have missed
one of our slides.
Never mind.
OK, right.
Coming on to "Codex
Amiatinus," this
is the book that has
been prefigured in what
Claire was saying to you.
This is-- for those who
have been to the exhibition
will confirm-- this
is a gigantic book.
It's at least this big.
It takes three or four
people to carry it.
It is an extraordinary book
for many reasons, one of which
is its size.
It contains well over
1,000 pages, 1,030 pages,
so it contains the skins
of at least 500 animals,
possibly more than that.
These sorts of books can
tell us an enormous amount
about the animal
husbandry, the landscape,
the way in which
monasteries worked in order
to produce the natural
resources that you
need for production of books
on a grand scale of this sort.
The book is also important
because it's the earliest
complete Latin Bible.
It contains the translation
done by Saint Jerome
in the late fourth
century, but it's
the best translation of this.
So it is the version of the
Bible that, then, provides
the sort of [? stemmer, ?] if
you like, for understanding
the transmission
of the Latin Bible
through Europe through
the Middle Ages.
It is important because this
book was made in England,
in Northumbria, at
the monastery where
the Venerable Bede was based.
It is, if you like, a
pastiche of an Italian book
of the sixth century,
and what it represents
is the ability of the
Northumbrian scribes
in the early eighth
century to produce
a book that was, to all
intents and purposes,
a perfect Italian book.
And it demonstrated
how well the English
had absorbed the lessons
of the missionaries who
had brought Christianity
to Anglo-Saxon England
from Rome round about 600.
Even more amazing, it was one
of three books of this type that
was made at Wearmouth-Jarrow.
And one was intended for Jarrow,
one for Wearmouth, and one--
this one-- to go to the pope.
And we know that it
was sent to the pope.
We've got an account written
at the time of the abbot
leaving Wearmouth-Jarrow
with this book
and taking it to Rome.
He didn't make it all the way.
He died in Burgundy
and was buried there.
But his men took--
the monks of Jarrow took
the book on to Rome,
where it was received
by Pope Gregory II,
and there it has stayed.
As Claire said, it has not
been back to England since it
left in 716.
When it came back to
the British Library
for the start of
this exhibition,
there were more than a
few tears in the room,
because this is a monument of
European, of world culture.
And to bring it back to
Britain for the first time
was very important.
What you can probably
see if you look
at the screen is what you've
got on the left-hand side
is the dedication page.
Now, we have the dedication
in its original form
in this account from Northumbria
in the early eighth century,
but you can probably see
how it's been altered.
Can you see it's
written in black ink,
and then someone's come
in and written in brown?
That was somebody in Italy
appropriating this book
for the Italian monastery.
And so all the way
through the Middle Ages,
it was believed that this
was an Italian sixth century
book until somebody
spotted the correlation
between the dedication
inscription in the manuscript
and in this text, whereby it
was sort of re-realized that it
was, in fact, a book
made in Northumbria
in the early eighth
century at the monastery
of Wearmouth-Jarrow when the
Venerable Bede was alive.
SIMON KEYNES: Right.
Now we go-- we've had
one charter from 679.
This, now, is another
original charter.
We're moving into the period of
the Mercian Supremacy, a period
in the eighth century when
the Mercian kings in the West
Midlands were
dominant in England.
And in this case,
it's dated 736.
You can see that script are
as [? tight ?] [? cartular. ?]
It's now using a system of
dating with which we are
familiar, which was
introduced into the country
by the Venerable Bede himself.
And again, he's called--
he was king of the
Mercians, but the scribe
in writing that has
said, I, Aethelbald,
by gift of God, King,
not only of the Mercians,
but of all of the kingdoms which
go by the general name South
English.
So the scribe is conscious that
Aethelbald is more than a king
of the Mercians.
And in fact, when he gets
down to the witness list,
he's getting so
overexcited by this
that he actually calls
Aethelbald king of Britain,
which is obviously a
gross exaggeration,
but that's par for the course.
And again, in this case, you
can see that the document
has been used in ceremony.
Names have been added.
The document was
written in advance,
and some names have
been inserted there
and added at the bottom there.
You can tell that from
the different ink.
So again, we see what
charters themselves
can deliver at all stages
of Anglo-Saxon England
in substantiating what
we otherwise learn
from the books in general.
JOANNA STORY: And the
charter of this sort
is written in a script that
we call uncial, which is also
the script that's used for
writing the poshest gospel
books in that sort
of Roman context.
So we can tell
something about who
the scribes are who are
writing the charters as well
as the books.
OK.
So sticking with
the eighth century,
and moving on into the
ninth century as well,
this is one of these very, very
sort of luscious, deluxe gospel
books that was written,
probably in Kent,
round about the middle
years of the eighth century,
so around the sort of
750s, that sort of period.
And this one is here
for two reasons,
partly because it is a
part of what was clearly
a very, very sumptuous book
written with copious amounts
of gold and silver.
But also, some of the
other pages in this book
are dip dyed in purple
with all of the resonance
of imperial Roman connotations
that go with that.
And it's possible that those
dipped purple pages might also
have been imported, perhaps
from as far away as Byzantium.
So this type of manuscript--
you can see here
in sort of epigraphic
capitals the beginning
of the generation of Christ,
the part of the Bible
that explains Christ's lineage.
The X at the top is part of
the name of Christ in Greek,
but you can see it with all of
these curls and swirls, which
are reminiscent of Celtic
or Irish style of art
as well being used
in this manuscript.
This manuscript is also here
to take us into the next phase,
if you like, of Anglo-Saxon
history in the ninth century,
because you can
probably see the top
and bottom of this ornate
page are little lines
of writing in little letters.
And this is, in fact,
written in Old English,
so in the vernacular.
And it records an incident
whereby this book was ransomed
for three bags of gold from
heathen invaders, heathen
pirates, and we're talking
here about Vikings.
And this man whose
name was Alfred--
it's not King Alfred,
but the Alderman Alfred--
ransomed these books
and brought them
and gave them to the church
at Canterbury in order
that Canterbury thereafter might
remember himself, and his wife,
and his daughter
in their prayers
in perpetuity as
a sort of thanks
for the rescuing of the word
of God in this manuscript.
So we've got here in this book
an extraordinary eighth century
book that was clearly
snaffled by the Vikings,
not because they
could give a monkey's
about the content of what
it said, but probably
because it had an ornate,
jeweled cover on the front.
They may also have realized that
they could get some gold for it
if there was someone who
was prepared to buy it back
from them.
Interestingly also,
you might just
be able to notice in the
margin the name of Aethelred.
Here is the name of his
wife, and here is the name
of his daughter along the side.
Aethelred-- sorry--
Alfred's name
is near the name of Christ.
His wife's name here
comes alongside the word
"mater," so this is in reference
to Mary, the mother of God.
And the daughter's name is
alongside a section which says,
"in utero [? happens," ?]
holding in her womb.
So the placing of
the names, at least
of the wife and the daughter,
reflects that generation
of Christ.
It says quite a lot
about Alfred's sense
of his own importance
that he goes
alongside the name of Christ.
But as they read out
this text, if you like,
the memory of
these three people,
these benefactors to the
community at Canterbury
who saved this book
from the Vikings,
is sort of hoovered
up in the prayers that
go with the community every
time this book is used and read
in that sort of
liturgical setting.
SIMON KEYNES: Now we go
again from the sublime
to the ridiculous.
This is the back of a charter.
It can't get much
worse than that.
What one has to do is
imagine that on the front
of this charter there is a
very significant text marking
the agreement of--
marking the making
of an agreement
between the Church of
Canterbury and the Kings
of the West Saxons.
We're in the early part
of the ninth century.
And so on the front
of the charter,
there is the text of this thing.
And then on the top left, that's
the archbishop and the members
of his community sort
of signing the document,
agreeing to hold to it.
And it's a crucial
turning point.
We are moving away from
the Mercian Supremacy
to the emergence
of the West Saxons
and their special relationship
with the Archbishops
of Canterbury we've
just been hearing about.
The people with the document
took the document, then,
to Wilton in Wiltshire in the
kingdom of the West Saxons,
and there it was confirmed by
King Ecgberht and his son King
Aethelwulf.
And it's attested by
Aethelwulf and then the bishops
of Winchester and
Sherburn and then
all of the noblemen
of the West Saxons.
So the West Saxons
have endorsed it.
And then it's taken after
that to a church council,
and you can see there that the
bishops of the whole country
also acknowledge this agreement
between Canterbury and Wessex.
So that's in effect-- it's 838--
it's symbolic of
this great turn which
establishes the special
relationship between Canterbury
and Wessex and then leads to
the rise of Wessex in the later
ninth century and to everything
else that came thereafter,
which we'll see.
JOANNA STORY: OK.
So we're looking at this
shift in the balance of power
to the kingdom of Wessex.
And this is where
we first really hear
of one of the major
achievements, if you like,
of that West Saxon dynasty.
This is a book
associated directly
with King Alfred himself.
King Alfred, he died in
899, one of those very easy
dates to remember.
Now, Alfred's dynasty--
we've seen the 838 charter--
is coming to power against a
backdrop of external pressure,
particularly from Viking
raiders, Scandinavian raiders,
who start the process with
these sort of hit and run
raids on the coast.
And then gradually, you get the
build-up of much larger armies
that are overwintering
and staying
for several years campaigning.
The West Saxon kingdom
was the last, if you like,
the last kingdom standing after
the other Anglo-Saxon kingdoms
had been--
the dynasties had been taken
out by Scandinavian armies.
And Alfred is well
remembered in history
as the West Saxon king who is
really responsible for stopping
that Viking onslaught and
maintaining the power of Wessex
and starting to rebuild
the power of Wessex.
Towards the end of
his reign, there
comes this period of relative
peace and prosperity in Wessex,
and Alfred is able to shift
his attention to something
that he had always been
interested in, which
was learning.
And he understood that
the English kingdoms--
he thought that one of the
reasons why the English
kingdoms had been so badly
damaged and so badly targeted
by these external raiders
was that they were not
sufficiently, if you like,
sufficiently good Christians
in order to be able to--
God was punishing them
for their lack of faith.
But he also
understood that there
had been such degradation
over the years of the ability,
of the resources in England,
to learn that he said,
we've got to do
something radical.
What we've got to do is rebuild
the sort of Christianity
across the kingdom, but there
are not enough people anymore
who can read and write in Latin.
He said, before everything
was ransacked and burned,
we had the ability.
We had people all over the
place who could read and write
in Latin, and people would come
to England to learn from us.
But now, he says, there
is scarcely anyone south
of the Humber who is competent.
So he said, we must
do things differently,
and we must do it in English.
And this is, if you
like, the greatest
legacy of King Alfred to our
modern day, where he turns
English from the
vernacular, spoken language
of the ordinary people
into a literary language,
which is appropriate
for use in the church.
And this manuscript
is where he lays out
that manifesto, if you
like, of the use of English
alongside Latin as a language
that can be there to reinforce,
to re-establish the
Christian morals and ethos
of the English people.
And this is where
he lays it out.
And this is a manuscript
that dates almost certainly
to the last decade of
the ninth century where
Alfred writes to Bishop
Werferth laying out this agenda.
And what thereafter
follows is a translation
into English of the
"Pastoral Care," which
had been composed
by Pope Gregory
the Great, the pope who had
sent the missionaries to England
in round about 600.
Whereas Gregory the Great
had seen the "Pastoral Care"
as a handbook for
bishops, really Alfred
sees the "Pastoral Care"
translated into English
as a handbook for kings
about how to operate
and how to be a good king.
SIMON KEYNES: Well, that's
Alfred the Great at his finest.
He had a son and grandson.
The son was called
Edward the Elder.
The grandson was the
person responsible
for a magnificent
series of charters
in the 930s, which represent
the first establishment
of a kingdom of the English.
We're no longer the
kingdom of the West Saxons.
Things have moved forward
in the early 10th century,
and this is a product
of this new kingdom.
And you can see at a glance
what an extraordinary number
of people attend these
royal assemblies.
This was issued--
it's dated incredibly
accurately-- the
12th of November,
931 at Lifton in Devon.
There was this council meeting.
And the document itself
is just a grant of land
to a miscellaneous person,
but you can see here's
the King and all of his bishops.
Here are all of the
aldermen, the Dukes,
the Earls of the kingdom coming
from Wessex, coming from Kent,
coming from northern
England, eastern England.
Some have weird names.
[? Thorfath, ?] [? Hada, ?]
[? Skoler, ?] these are all
Norse names.
These are representatives
of the Viking invaders.
Then, some abbots,
and then lots and lots
of thanes of
miscellaneous people.
And this is typical of
diplomas of the 10th century
granting land to individuals.
And in this particular case,
the will of the beneficiary
is attached to the
bottom edge, and he
grants to land to Winchester.
And Claire has very kindly
lent me the charter,
and you can get a sense of
what these documents look
like in parchment.
You can pass this round, and
I'm very grateful to her.
But it gives you some sense of
if you own that document you
would own the land.
You could go to court and
just waive the document
at the people in the
court, and the fact
that you had the title
deed would be enough.
Anyway, it's a
magnificent document.
JOANNA STORY: Even
better than the original.
OK.
One of the things I was like
about these witness lists--
and Simon pointed out this
group of Norse names--
is you can kind of
imagine that the committee
room, and the Scandinavians are
sitting in the corner together.
And as they go around
and mark off who's there,
you've got this little
group of Scandinavians
sitting in the corner.
You know what it's like.
Students, they always
sit in the same place.
I'm sure that's
what was going on.
OK.
Right.
So here we come
to our poster boy
for the exhibition, King Edgar.
Now, Edgar ruled
from 959 to 975,
so we're well into the middle
years of the 10th century here.
And Edgar really picks up
on the legacy of Athelstan,
who we've just heard about,
who is one of the kings
to really start to define
a kingdom of the English
for the first time.
And Edgar takes that forward.
And he does that in a
number of different ways,
but one of the things
he's most associated with
is a wholesale
reform of the church,
because he sees the church--
just like Alfred had
done before him--
as an essential sort of
partner in the running
of a medieval kingdom, in
the running of his kingdom.
And just as he sees the
kingdom as a unified whole,
so he sees the church as
a unified whole as well.
So he talks about one
church and one kingdom.
But he sees that the
church needs reform,
and it needs reform
along the lines
of the rule of Saint
Benedict, the sixth century
monk from Italy who produced a
rule known as the Benedictine
rule.
Edgar and his followers
decide that this
needs to be implemented in
Anglo-Saxon England in a more
systematic way than
had been done before.
So under Edgar and
his key reformers,
people like Bishop Aethelwold,
Archbishop Dunstan,
and Wulfstan of York as well
are reforming important churches
through the kingdom,
not all of them,
but key churches including
the church at Winchester,
the Old Minster at Winchester,
which is, if you like,
the West Saxon capital.
And this book is,
in fact, a charter.
It's the Great Charter for the
reformed Minster at Winchester,
but very unusually in the form
of a book rather than as one
of these single-sheet charters.
And that's because
it's so long, and it
goes on for sort of 60 pages
but all written in gold.
But at the front of it, you
have this portrait of King Edgar
donating the charter-- you
can see it in his hand there--
to Christ, who is seen
in the mandala above them
with Saint Peter and Mary
on either side of him.
Christ shown in that mandala
like that, the intersection
of two circles, the heavenly
sphere and the earthly sphere,
Christ in majesty in between.
And so just as we had
that image of Athelstan
that Claire showed us that
the beginning donating
a copy of the "Life of
Saint Cuthbert" to Saint
Cuthbert himself, here
you have King Edgar
presenting the charter
for the new Minster,
the reformed church,
to Christ himself.
And then the text of it follows
in the 60 odd pages thereafter.
SIMON KEYNES: Right.
Well, I'm afraid it goes
pear shaped after that,
because the Vikings came
back in even larger numbers
than they'd been here before
under King Sweyn Forkbeard
and then Sweyn's son, King Cnut.
And with the English
under the impressive rule
of King Aethelred the Unready,
you can imagine what happened.
And the Danes conquered
the English in 1016.
This is, however, a magnificent
charter of King Cnut,
and it shows how once he
became king, in effect
he had nothing to bring
himself, and he took over
all of the English institutions
which had developed.
And Athelstan's charter,
which we looked at,
is in a script known
as square minuscule.
This is in a
beautiful script known
as Anglo-Caroline
minuscule, which
is the ancestor of the script
that we all write today.
And it's just a
grant by the king.
Most interestingly, it's
also issued at the request
of his wife, Queen Aelfgifu.
And that shows
how significant it
was to him that he married
the widow of King Aethelred
the Unready, and in this way,
he was able to ingratiate
himself-- well, he
thought he might
be able to ingratiate
himself so much the more
with the English people.
It's a stunning document.
Again, you can analyze
all of the names.
There's Cnut, the
Archbishop of York,
Wulfstan, Aelfgifu, the queen,
and then several bishops,
several abbots.
And then here you have one
of the chief Scandinavians,
[? Thirkettle, ?]
Thorkell the Tall.
And then here is Godwine.
That's Earl Godwin, the father
of Harold who became king.
This is in 1018, the first
year of Cnut's reign,
and you can see
already there were
sort of warnings of what's going
to happen good many years later
with the Norman conquest.
JOANNA STORY: I mean, another
interesting thing to just
pick out here while we've
got this one on the screen is
that you can probably see
that the script changes
to a much sort of, if you
like, sort of smaller point
size and a different font,
to use modern terminology.
This is the parcel of land.
It's a description
of the parcel of land
that's being donated
in the charter,
and it's in Old English.
So the main framework of
the charter is in Latin,
but when it switches
to describing
the actual bit of the
land that is to be given,
they revert to the
vernacular so that it's
absolutely clear to
everybody listening
precisely where this is.
And these charter bounds
go so far as to say,
you go up to the holly tree
at the top of the hill,
and then you come
down the valley
until you get to the stream
and then along and around.
And you can imagine
this being read aloud
in the Old English vernacular so
that everybody in the locality
actually, really understood the
precise boundary of land that
was being donated.
And one of the
extraordinary things
about so many of these
Anglo-Saxon charters
is that we can reconstruct very
often these absolute parcels
of land that are
available that were being
given, including some, in fact,
for land parcels in London
itself.
And you can walk the bounds of
these charters within the city
today.
Claire, won't you come up.
CLAIRE BREAY: Thank you.
So I showed before an image
of "Domesday Book," which is
near the end of the exhibition.
And as I said, "Domesday Book"
contains this incredible detail
covering most of
the country, and it
reflects the organization
of the country.
And it's organized by
the shires which had
emerged in the 10th century.
And that organization of
the shires, the counties,
their boundaries lasted until
local government reorganization
in 1974, so it's a
very long-lived legacy
of the late Anglo-Saxon period.
But "Domesday" also
shows the wealth
that existed in England
in the 11th century,
and of course, it
was that wealth--
and the organization
of the country--
that made England so attractive
to Cnut in his conquest of 1016
and to William of Normandy,
more famously, in 1066.
So that organization of the
country is a great legacy,
but the other great legacy is
the English language itself.
And as I said at
the beginning, that
is something that
we've embedded right
throughout the exhibition.
Looking from the earliest uses
of short pieces of English
in runic characters inscribed
on objects and the "Textus
Roffensis," that
earliest extended
text in the English language,
we look at the use of English
with Latin as a
literary language.
But right at the end
of the exhibition,
we have this manuscript,
which shows the continuity
of the English language.
This manuscript is a
very large, the book
of the psalms known as the
"Eadwine Psalter" on loan
to us from Trinity
College in Cambridge.
And it is one of three psalters
that are displayed together.
And it's displayed with the
"Utrecht Psalter," which I also
showed earlier, which
has those cartoon
strip-like drawings of
those very lively characters
from the psalms.
And through the display of
these three manuscripts,
we're trying to bring out--
or bring together--
some of the themes that
run right through the
exhibition, not just
the continuity of the
English language, which I'll
come onto in a moment, but
the themes of connectedness
and contacts between
the Anglo-Saxon kingdoms
and their neighbors in Ireland
and continental Europe,
because the "Utrecht
Psalter," as I said,
was made on the continent
in the 9th century.
And it was a manuscript
that came to Canterbury,
and a copy was made of it.
Now, it was used
as a model there
at the beginning
of the 11th century
for a manuscript in
our own collections
known as the "Harley Psalter."
And then this manuscript,
the "Eadwine Psalter,"
was produced in the middle
of the 12th century.
It didn't include all
the illustrations,
but it does incorporate the
three different versions
of the psalms in Latin
whereas only one had
been included before.
And so that's why it's got
these three columns of text.
And very interestingly,
between the lines
of the Latin in the
right-hand column,
the psalms have been translated
into Anglo-Norman French,
reflecting the new reality
following the Norman conquest.
But between the lines
of the middle column
of the psalms in
Latin, the Psalms
are translated into
English, showing
the continuity of
the English language
well into the 12th century.
I hope-- well, I've
seen that several of you
been to the exhibition, and
I hope that many more of you
might have been inspired by
looking at these manuscripts
and charters today to go.
Very sadly for us, it closes
on the 19th of February.
It's extremely busy, so
I do advise you to book
ahead if you'd like to go.
But it has been an absolutely
incredible experience
working on the exhibition.
We were-- or I was-- indebted
to the advisory group who helped
to develop the exhibition.
And Simon and Jo were absolutely
key members of that group,
and they both were
very great contributors
to the catalog as well.
And Jo edited the catalog
with me for her sins.
And I think-- yeah, it has
been an incredible project
to work on, and I don't
think this group of,
well, manuscripts and charters
will be together again
certainly in our lifetimes.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank you very much.
We do have time for questions.
Please wait for the microphone.
AUDIENCE: What is the
difference between a charter
and a manuscript?
JOANNA STORY: OK.
Manuscript literally
means "written by hand,"
so charters are
manuscripts, if you like.
But the objects I
was talking about
were books, a codices, a
codex, whereas a charter--
the ones that Simon was showing
you-- were on single sheets,
so single sheets of parchment.
And when we're talking
about parchment,
we're talking
about animal skins.
So in Anglo-Saxon England,
it's mostly cattle skin,
but increasingly, also the use
of sheep or goat skin as well.
If you can get the
images back up--
can you get the images back up?
We might be to sort of
point to some things.
So one of the interesting
things about those charters
that we looked at, I
don't know if you saw
they had sort of lines on them.
Did you see that?
That's how they were folded
up, so you can reconstruct
how they were all folded up.
And some of these
original charters--
so these are things that
were written in 838 or 736--
were folded up into
little squares this big
that somehow have survived.
And that, I think, is
one of the really sort
of mind blowing things, that
these little, tiny things that
have been folded up and
kept over the years,
very often in the context
of the church that
was the beneficiary of the
land that was being granted.
So a charter is a legal
document that records
the grant of land or privilege.
Lots of them survive in copies
in codices, manuscripts,
but some of them-- and
we've got quite a lot--
survive in those original forms.
So they're original legal
documents from 1,000 years ago.
CLAIRE BREAY: And
we have quite a lot,
but a huge amount
has also been lost.
And I think that's one of the
different things about curating
an exhibition on
this sort of period
compared with something even
later in the Middle Ages, let
alone a more modern subject.
The evidence is
very fragmentary.
I worked on the Magna
Carta exhibition
at the British Library
a few years ago,
and my research had a
spreadsheet with two
and a half thousand
possible exhibits on it.
And there just aren't that many
manuscripts surviving at all
from Anglo-Saxon English, so
you're choosing from a smaller
pool of what survives.
But I think one of the
interesting things that we've
tried to get people to think
about in the exhibition
is how you use that
fragmentary evidence to tell
the story of what was
actually happening
and to get visitors to engage
with the difficulties of having
to try and extrapolate so much,
often from very small pieces
of evidence that survive.
JOANNA STORY: I mean, there's
an important sort of point
of principle there, which
is that medievalists
work from data.
We work from
evidence, but you also
have to have a really
good imagination
to make the leap
between the evidence
and then to back it up.
So we tell good
stories because we've
got the imagination to do it.
But the evidence, the data
is what underpins it all.
AUDIENCE: Why did so many
people sign the charters?
Was it to increase the
legitimacy of the document
or to increase the
prestige of the people--
meaning I was here when
this charter was made?
SIMON KEYNES: Well, I
think the essential point
is that these charters are
products of the royal assembly
at which they were produced.
And so the witness
list is symbolic
of that fact, the fact that
this is not just the king
making an act.
It's the king in
consultation with,
and with the permission of,
the bishops, and the earls,
and the men of the land.
So one shouldn't
think that they're
necessarily all
lining up and sort
of signing the document itself.
It's more of a symbolic
representation of a royal act
proceeding from
a royal assembly,
and that's very much
a part of the way
that the Anglo-Saxons
saw it themselves.
JOANNA STORY: So you're right.
It is for the--
it's really both of
those things you say.
It's for the prestige
of the people
as well as ensuring
that the record
of that transfer of
land-- because the source
of all wealth is land, was
then, is now, ever shall be.
So the transfer of
land in perpetuity
into the church is something
that they want to make sure
is recorded and witnessed by
as many people as possible.
So the charter, if you like,
is a record both of the event
as it occurs-- a bit
like a video record--
but it's also picking up
other people who agree to it
and agreed that this
transfer has taken place
in the presence of the king.
CLAIRE BREAY: And I think
one of the amazing things
about the documents
in the exhibition
is that I think they do
sort of transport you back
to that moment in time and
to when a group of people
were there.
Or with the wills
there's somebody
dealing with their
property, and it gives you
a connection with the
individuals and the occasion
when they were created, which
I think is very powerful.
And I think people
visiting the exhibition
have found it very,
very powerful.
Although I think, in
curating an exhibition,
there is a tension
between what is visually
appealing to visitors and
what is the most historically
important, Simon.
SIMON KEYNES: Yes.
CLAIRE BREAY: So, Simon--
SIMON KEYNES: Claire.
CLAIRE BREAY: Simon was
very keen, very, very keen
to have some charters in the
exhibition which were extremely
important, which I deemed
to be undisplayable
much to his distress.
So, yeah--
JOANNA STORY: I can't
tell you what she really
said about them.
[LAUGHTER]
We are not having
that on our wall.
It might be historically
very significant,
but it cannot be displayed.
CLAIRE BREAY: Yeah.
It has to be
something that people
are going to stop and look at.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are you
trying to tell the story
of the English
language, and was it
possible that the English
language could have died out?
It was fragile, wasn't
it, when the Normans came?
It could have died out.
We could have been
speaking French.
I mean, are you
telling a history
of the English language?
JOANNA STORY: Yes, certainly
it is there as well.
I mean, as Claire said, there
are fragments of English--
written English--
from right at the
beginning of the period.
So when you first go
into the exhibition,
there are little runic
inscriptions written in English
that show the earliest
phases of the language.
It is revived under
King Alfred and is
made into a literary
language for the church.
It clearly existed in
the form of epic poetry
in a very sort of
sophisticated way before that,
but it then becomes written down
as a language of composition
for the church and for
thinking and knowledge
exchange from
Alfred's time onward,
so the end of the
11th and 12th century.
When French starts being used
in England after the Norman
conquest, it is a
language of the elite.
So it is a language
of government.
It's a language of the church.
But the vernacular language,
the spoken language,
remains English
to a large degree.
You get loanwords
coming in from French,
those things like "beef"
comes from [FRENCH]
and "mutton," [FRENCH].
Those are the
words of the table,
but they're not the words
of the spoken people.
"Swine," [GERMAN]
from the Germans.
So you can see the
language borrowing,
but English remains
through the conquest.
So there's a very strong
line of continuity in that
the other side the conquest.
So I don't think it is quite
as fragile as you might have
thought, but that's partly to
do with the nature of the regime
change that you see
in the 11th century,
first under Cnut and then
under William beyond that.
AUDIENCE: How often do new
manuscripts come to light?
Let's say if you were to
have done this exhibition 10
years ago, would it be
almost exactly the same
as it is now, or
are there new things
that have been discovered?
CLAIRE BREAY: So
one of the most--
JOANNA STORY: Sorry.
Sorry.
I was going to say the
"Anderson Pontifical."
SIMON KEYNES: Yeah.
CLAIRE BREAY: OK.
Well, you can do that.
I'll do this one.
So one of the most
interesting things,
I think, for me
is the discovery,
through the
multispectral imaging
of Christina Duffy, who
is in the audience today,
of the "Bodmin Gospels."
So in the "Bodmin
Gospels," which
are a ninth century
Breton gospel
book which ended up
in Cornwall, there
is a page which looks
completely blank.
But Christina, who
works at the library,
did some multispectral
imaging on this page for us,
and the text of five documents--
they're manumission documents
recording the freeing
of slaves in Cornwall.
And so this hidden
documentary evidence,
which had never
been seen before,
came to light through
the new imaging.
And this was a
manuscript that had
been in the national
collection for over 200 years,
so sometimes there
are new things
to be discovered in manuscripts
that we already know about.
And I think these
documents are especially
interesting because they
are the freeing of slaves,
so there is information about
people who aren't recorded
in any other sources at all.
But yes, there's also the
"Anderson Pontifical," which
was a spectacular discovery.
SIMON KEYNES: Yes, if I can just
add that every now and then,
a new Anglo-Saxon
manuscript might appear.
The best-known and
well-represented
in the exhibition
is a manuscript
known as the "Anderson
Pontifical," which
was discovered in
a Scottish hayloft.
Someone was just sort of going
through their old plowshares
or whatever, and
suddenly they found
this stunningly
beautiful early 11th
century Anglo-Saxon
pontifical, which
is a book containing
all of the services
that a bishop would use.
And so there's the
coronation order,
which is much like the one
that survives to this day.
So that's a complete manuscript.
Charters can also come
to light, not necessarily
in their original
form, but in the form
of early modern
transcripts or whatever.
But what we really
want is for you
lot to devise some
kind of machine that
enables us to discover
manuscripts in the same way
that metal detectorists are
discovering hoards, gold,
silver.
We read about it every day
almost in the newspapers.
Metal detectorists
contribute a massive amount,
and what we want is a
machine which can identify
Anglo-Saxon--
JOANNA STORY: A book detector!
SIMON KEYNES: --books just
underneath the surface.
And then we can dig them up.
So there is a difference--
JOANNA STORY: I mean, one--
a complete manuscript was
discovered in a bog in Ireland
a few years ago, the
"Faddan More Psalter,"
which came out that sort
of anaerobic environment
of the bog, which was a very
important new discovery.
CLAIRE BREAY: --2006, yes.
In a bit of a state,
but nevertheless.
JOANNA STORY: Alphabet
soup it was described as.
CLAIRE BREAY: Yeah.
I mean, there were
two big exhibitions
on this period at the British
Museum, which Simon actually
contributed to.
In 1991, there was the
Making of England exhibition,
and the subtitle for that was
Art and Culture 600 to 900.
And in 1984, there
was the Golden Age
of Anglo-Saxon Art looking at
the later Anglo-Saxon period.
But I think the focus
of those exhibitions
was very much more
on art and style,
whereas the focus
of this exhibition
is more on the history.
There were a lot of manuscripts
in those other exhibitions
which are in this exhibition
covering the whole period,
but we've got all
those loans that
are in Britain for
the first time,
so they weren't included
in those exhibitions.
And we do have a large number
of illuminated manuscripts,
but we are, I think, using them
to tell a historical story.
And the great thing
about manuscripts
is that they have many pages,
so we, in many, many cases,
chose to show a different
opening from the ones that
were shown in those
exhibitions and are
recorded in those catalogs.
SPEAKER: I think we could easily
fill another hour of this,
but we are unfortunately
out of time.
So again, thank you very much.
CLAIRE BREAY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]